I don't know what gay people like don't
they just like normal [__] like [__]
frozen yogurt
[Music]
who knows anything about the gay version
of the Olympics no what
there's a gay version yeah
I swear like have I ended
have I been tonight so there's been 11
of them I didn't know there was a gay
Olympics it's called the gay games yeah
man the gay games is it like who can be
gayer than the other one no but it's not
about being gay like that
they have sports events just like the
Olympics but everyone's gay oh cool what
the hell I mean that's like just gave me
but in this one you have to be gay so
it's been going on since 1982. what
straight guys can't get in there dude
well I mean I guess you could
technically they can't stop me though
right I mean they'll be discriminating I
think they would believe it's believable
if you did it nice I think so too so in
1982 was the how do they screen to make
sure you're gay right they'll be like
kiss me kiss me kiss me
auditions you can't flip okay it's a
casting couch I actually don't know how
they screened it but there's been some
Olympic events where uh where there were
more participants in the gay games and
they were in the real really what but so
it started in 1982 the first one was in
San Francisco and then
um they did it there the next time as
well 1990 moved to Canada 94 was in New
York 98 it was in the Netherlands
2002 was in Australia it's a legit
[__] organization it is legit it's
super legit so they do every four years
too every four years yeah and they do
the same [__] like shot put [__]
track swimming yeah are they represented
by countries they have like 30 to 35
sports events per Olympics they'll have
like like uh like look at it look at
this the first one there was 1350
participants in the last one there was
ten thousand whoa participants yeah whoa
that's crazy amazing and then um but is
it like the sparta race where everyone
just does it and it's not like um like
the Olympics where you have like
lifelong athletes and [__] I would say a
little bit there are less uh parameters
that you have to meet in order to
qualify maybe there's none at all
sometimes I'm not sure you have to run
specific ways
[Laughter]
you know I mean like
I don't know what's the audition like
how do you know I don't even know how
the auditions are you just say you just
say you're gay because what if you just
like sports probably yeah like what if
you really like sports and just like
there's not enough competitions in the
world and then they're like I found
another one that I can go join you know
what's funny is that there was one point
in time where they were gonna um hold
the gay games in Montreal but there was
a disagreement over like uh how to do it
so Montreal split off and they made
their own like uh the out games or
something like that the out games
something like that out something but
then um so they ended up splitting the
market so there's two now
yeah so there was like a internal gay
battle Yeah but the gay games is
definitely still doing better than the
Republic of the Montreal one yeah
Montreal one lost a lot of money it's
like the NFL you can't be the usfl you
can't be except you can't be none of
that it's just gay games got a monopoly
on gay sports yeah it's pretty cool so
in 2018 they had it in Paris France
where do you think they're having it
next it's probably uh Saudi Arabia the
most let's how about let's yeah let's
rule out places I think right on Brazil
probably not you keep looking at next
something in Pasadena
in the front is it in America it's not
in America not in America let's just say
this it's in a place where some people
don't want it to be there oh even though
every time they do it someone doesn't
want it to be there but like people
really don't want this people are real
pissed about like Morocco
no it's not Morocco is it is it an area
where yeah Philippines dude that would
kill in the Philippines oh really they
support that stuff that the dark day was
gonna be like big boy bad boy jersey's
not even in power anymore okay never
mind Malaysia you heard her answer China
China
close Taiwan
close closer Hong Kong
but why don't people want to know they
don't they're not they're not like uh
homophobic and Hong Kong well there's
some human rights there's some human
rights activists that are protesting it
and I found that to sound strange I was
like human rights activists don't want
yeah that would mean they would they
would want it I think there's something
in the politics with uh the gay games
and with the China stuff oh I see oh
that's right Hong Kong's
yeah owned by China but they're like you
can govern yourself if you want to
there's a conflict of interesting heavy
China influence yeah but they go oh but
that I think you shouldn't and then
they're like too much micromanaging from
China yeah so there's a bunch of
protests trying to take down the gay
games from happening in Hong Kong but
the gay games have responded saying that
no matter what happens they are not
going to cancel it wow do you have any
stats from the gay games yeah like just
comparison like let's say like 100 meter
sprint from regular Olympics to like I
want to see how far like oh like the
actual sports stats yeah I don't have
those but um I got some facts about it
yeah yeah all right so uh here's some
interesting things I want to see
pictures yeah me too I don't want to see
videos he's laughing already I think my
imagination
yeah all right I need to like what kind
of colors do you think if it's not like
Pride I'm gonna be so it looks honestly
it looks pretty freaking cute because
like I feel like like the gay community
always always does things with like
Pizzazz they do things better a lot so
so like yeah it's like Olympics is just
Bland because you're just like
athleticism ugh like what about those
uniforms yeah what about pageantry dude
um come on but then some of the sports
they had in the in the very first one
they had basketball track and field
bowling volleyball wrestling swimming
and this and Tina Turner would perform
the opening ceremony wow wow is he still
alive in the first one 82. but the
Olympics actually suit the gay games at
one point really because originally the
name was the Gay Olympics end of the
Olympics are like you can't do that see
I told you they should have called it
Gay Olympics yeah make it all one but
Gay Olympics uh kind of it's kind of
unfair because they do have the Special
Olympics the new Olympics police
Olympics and dog Olympics and they can't
have Gay Olympics they have police
Olympics and Olympics didn't sue any of
them to change maybe because back then
when you when you're like oh the
Olympics are so gay like you know how
when you said stuff like that so then
like the Olympics got offended because
you're like hey don't call us gay we're
not the Gay Olympics yeah so like maybe
that's why they didn't like it
yes oh yeah but to answer your question
on some of the athleticism uh there are
some world records that were set at the
Gay Olympics wow yeah all right look at
some serious athletes of something that
just in case you were wondering America
are those kids it almost no they're like
I don't think they're kids I bet they
have more fun at the Gay Olympics than
they do with the regular it almost looks
like AI that image
um another fun fact is uh did you guys
hear about the Olympics is just like a
hardcore [__] fest with with athletes
and the best specimens of the world yeah
at the Olympic Village right yeah I
heard that there's always you always
find condoms everywhere this time and
everyone stuffs their mouths full of
McDonald's which is crazy yeah that's
like these are the top genetic people in
the universe so they could eat
McDonald's and still be like buff so
they have uh it's a usually they have
like in the village McDonald's has a
24-hour restaurant because they sponsor
the Olympics and everyone just can't
wait to go there and just get especially
if you're from a different country too
yeah like you're from Iraq you can go to
like get all the McDonald's you want and
they'll pack it and I'll bring it back
home just because it won't go bad yeah
it lasts forever no but uh like that's
one of the main things they're just
hyped to have McDonald's and they're
they have Elite genetics so they eat
fish fillet again yeah I think the way
their body can convert things is just
not normal you know it's not fair not
fair at all I wonder how many people got
pregnant from the Olympics that's the
best place though yeah Elite genetics
and then you inseminate with Elite
genetics make super children stamina
strong so they probably go forever yeah
they're probably busting it down all the
time probably but then I wonder if they
come and then get tired and then they
lose
I bet it happens to some people I bet
some people party a little too hard
right you know especially if it's their
first Olympics and it's like they're a
little too excited can you imagine how
many people like lost because of that
because they party too hard I bet that's
a thing for sure is there an Olympic
event that's comprised of athletes that
do not have ideal looking bodies there's
a ton of them like what like what a
shock put yeah a shot put there's like a
lot of fat dudes yeah they don't they
don't look like what you think is
athletic until they move oh when they
move you're like oh my God this [__]
300 pound person is very graceful and
explosive what about the arch like the
archery dudes or the shooters they
probably look normal they don't look
like yeah on either end of the spectrum
or like the ping pong Stars they look
like you just beat them up yeah but
their forearms are probably cute they
got crazy hops they're like [__]
springy and it's the Cavs
or the power walkers have you seen the
power walker what that's in the Olympics
they're probably just real lean the
prizes Like rules have you ever looked
at speed walking times I thought I was a
fast speedwalker so I was like oh maybe
I could try out they do a mile in like
uh five minutes 5 30.
so the balloon with speed walking is
that one foot has to be like faster than
most people's running that's how crazy
these [__] are the rule is that
one foot has to be on the ground you
said or both one foot has to be on the
ground like both feet can't be off the
ground because when you run technically
you know you're what kind of sponsorship
can you get as a speed Walker Sketchers
A6 Korea Brooks
Korean Mizuno yeah Mizuno this guy's a
big Mizuno guy you're a big Mizuno man
I'm just not a nerd
I just like [__] so I know a lot about
[__] yeah
I think New Balances are really good
walking shoes
yeah that's true
more Brands anybody what are some brands
that would be great for gay games
I don't know what gay people like those
are just like normal [__] like [__]
frozen yogurt
hey I live in weho gelato I like frozen
yogurt oh yeah you can ask him what do
you think yeah what's a gay brand
because these days everyone's like
trying to Market to gay folks like
everybody everybody's like using the gay
community as a way to make Lululemon
yeah
that's a gay brand no no I'm wearing
Lulu I like Lulu is that Lululemon yeah
these are like 300 dude honestly how
much are those the whole time because
tip was like you should buy a new pair
like pants and I was like okay whatever
and I went to Lulu and I was like dude
I'm not gonna spend 100. their shit's
comfortable as [__] I put it on and I
was like okay I'm spending that much
money what's the difference why does it
it's just they just feel so once you put
them on you'll know you know who has
extraterrestrials Lululemon Factories do
they got some extraterrestrial [__]
technology look at what the it doesn't
make I'm literally pulling like his
pocket by like that's not my pocket what
do you mean so it just stretches that's
just why it's cool it's just it's just
good [__] like I don't know how else to
put it like honestly the best it's the
best on the market for sure
you can take it back so like if you get
a clear or something like a defective
like situation on your leggings or
something you just take it back no
receipt and they just give you no
receipt I couldn't imagine spending this
much money on work pants but
Santia
is pretty good too you can't take
anything back but they won't even be
there but can I share something Sue yes
I did buy a pair of fake Yeezys on that
website Teemu and let me tell you hey
can I tell you yeah very good really
thirty dollars they look real what do
they I don't even care if they look real
they feel great on my feet okay there
you go and I put these on and they feel
like [__] well what's the site
it's like Chinese Amazon have you seen
that the orange app because it's
everywhere they're giving you like
things Dirt Cheap like two bucks
for sure child labor but you know
everything's child labor what is this
why are you against children having work
yeah you're making money that's why
that's why I bought a lot of things off
a lot of us went through child labor
isn't it illegal to say that you bought
a fake thing and endorse it on YouTube
can I yeah I think it's illegal to do
that really yeah well this is a lot
allegedly yeah allegedly nice knowing
you
[Music]